foreign
we're back let's go to Ann and the home
of the Pirates Pittsburgh what's up Ann
um hi Dr Delaney how are you
um good a little nervous but um I'll get
to my question that I um and left for
your show yeah I'm not very good at this
you have nothing to be nervous about
nothing
um yeah I know it's just hey I don't
like my voice on tape it sounds great I
don't know it sounds great okay all
right my my question was about
um the
gas lighting versus
um someone's story like what's the
difference is because
um
I've heard that term thrown around a lot
especially in my house in the last year
or so and
um then I also heard
um between your show and your book and
you know a class I had at work recently
they talked about your people's stories
and the stories you tell yourself and I
just wanted the explanation of the
differences and then how I can deal with
um you know conversations around that
let's get
instead of making this very academic and
giving definitions let's what's the
actual challenge you're facing
are people accusing you of gaslighting
them or are people gaslighting you and
store like what are you actually facing
um well my my kids have said
um like my husband and I you know
um have gasolit them and
um it give me an example of a a way they
say you're gaslighting them or Gaslight
them
um like saying like with their childhood
and how how they perceive it versus
um give me an example give me an example
um let me think um
yeah
here's a here's my time here but here's
a couple of things because it's just
it's like an overwhelming layer of
heaviness over sure there's there's
um a few of us
um have ADHD I know I was diagnosed I
strongly believe my husband is too and
me too me too me too so yeah and the the
emotional dysregulation that had
happened in the house apparently was
causing
um
stress that you know when you walk
around like uh you're walking on
eggshells and waiting for somebody to
explode so that was I guess the
um what the kids lived with and yes
yesterday I asked my daughter about
um I had pictures of us on a bike ride
or were talking about a bike ride that
we took that was like it ended up being
this huge long bike ride
um
on this really nice Trail and I'm like
oh do you remember that she goes well if
Dad was there I blacked it out and
I'm just crushed by that yeah
so
here's some what I would call low-level
gaslighting that parents do to their
kids
hey Mom that hurt No it didn't
shut your mouth and sit down
hey Mom I'm really hungry no you're not
shut your mouth and sit down you're just
doing that I gotta go to the bathroom
you're just doing that because you want
you right so that's that's that can be a
little over gaslighting or hey Mom
last night you yelled at me and it
scared me I didn't yell at you
you're just hearing things again you're
always making up stories about me or hey
Mom it was really scary when you I
didn't do that
gaslighting is about power
it's about control and it's using
disorientation or self-doubt or
dishonesty as as your tool some people
gain control by just yelling they're
I've got bigger muscles than you I'm
bigger than you some people gain power
especially in a household and we call it
the one down position
like
okay okay I guess I just won't eat then
if everybody needs three pieces of pizza
I'll just I I'm fine I probably need to
lose five pounds anyway that's that's
like that's a way to gain control
another way to gain control is by
gaslighting making everything
that okay I'm not gonna eat now I can
lose well it's the definition doesn't
matter as much as it's just a way to try
to take back control of a room that you
feel you've lost control of sometimes
dads scream and yell sometimes mom's
screaming you out slam cabinets that is
a body that's dysregulated and it just
becomes over emotive I need to regain
power
some get real dads are the worst my wife
calls it Sunday afternoon dad
when I you can feel the atomic energy
pulsing out of me and I'm just sitting
there on the couch
and my kid will say Hey Dad I'll go what
but I don't yell I'm quiet and then the
kids know whoa just don't go around dad
and then they're like man you're hard to
be around on Sundays and I'm like I
didn't say anything I just say I'm being
violent with my silence right or moms
like around the Thanksgiving table I
guess
I didn't cook it right so next year I
guess we'll just go out because I'm and
that's a way to go no Mom you did a
great job you're so good right it's a
way to regain control gaslighting is a
way to gain control is
everybody's off kilter
everybody is questioning their own
experience of reality because somebody
who's smarter them or bigger than them
or has more control or autonomy is
telling them that their lived experience
is wrong
and so if your children grew up with two
parents with ADHD
and they were y'all were all over the
place and Scattered by the way my kid is
growing up with a dad with rampant ADHD
it's a context it's not an excuse I
still got to work to be on time I still
get right but my kids growing up with
that and so I've got to be cognizant of
what he's going to experience Downstream
and so
I here's my bigger question
why are you going to why are you
debating your kids on their stories on
their lived experiences why do you feel
the need to say hey you're remembering
this wrong instead of saying I'm so
sorry no I don't I I don't argue
actually with um it's just that term has
come up okay and
um my daughter my youngest one will
um she she is openly admitted that
she'll make up things to try to hurt me
okay
um because of
um the fact that she thought my husband
and I should get divorced and we didn't
we chose to work out a lot of the issues
why do you give your daughter a vote
um probably because she's threatened
suicide in the past that that's even
less that's even less of a reason to
give her a vote my kids do not have a
vote into my emotional regulation
they don't have my permission to hurt my
feelings
now it doesn't always work like that my
body will will react yeah right my my
the last conversation or
um attack that we had I um
I stayed like the soup Uber calm like I
thought who are you I'm not that I've
ever I don't I'm not the one who loses
the cool and gets super super crazy but
I just was able to
step back and just listen to what she
was saying and I was like well
um okay and you know sorry you're
hurting right now and then I just I took
myself and I said I can't talk to you
when you're like this and we agreed that
if we wanted to have conversations about
any of these issues that we do it in
front of a therapist
um but when she doesn't get her way it's
it's like full-blown attack and then I
just have to but you how old is she
um 18. 18. so I would sit down with my
child who's 18 and say I have some
boundaries
and I don't allow people
I don't allow adults
and allow kids
to call me when they're struggling and
use me at to throw grenades at as a
Target so that they make them they can
feel better about themselves
I don't allow that
I don't allow my boss to call and yell
at me so he or she feels better about
themselves I don't allow my friends or
family or strangers to use me as a
verbal punching bag so they feel better
about themselves and most certainly I'm
not going to let my child who has
admitted to me whenever I get down I
just lie about you because I can I can
twist a knife in your back or in your
front I don't care I I don't allow that
so from this point forward when you call
and you're in one of those moods and
you're trying to hurt me to make
yourself feel better I'm out of the
conversation I'm just opting out I love
you too much for that and I have too
much dignity and self-respect for that
and yeah they put it just put a period
at the end
right the um and when you said about the
boundary that's actually what the
conversation was about she she wanted to
watch a movie in her room and using my
Amazon account she wanted me to give her
the password no to my Amazon account and
I said yeah and that's not a boundary
I'm comfortable sharing I said I've got
it on I'll I'll put it on your TV
um but she couldn't find the remote she
said and I said and it's on the TV out
here so you could watch out here but she
she lost it and you know my struggle is
I'm trying to get
um make sure she graduates high school
because it didn't happen last year and
because of did what you did did what you
did last year work
well she's a still alive and she
re-enrolled in school so I'm not sure
because things were changed because last
year I was separated from my husband and
we were living in two places seeing each
other
um but that didn't seem to make it
better for her us being separated I
thought maybe she would be able to get
that
breath of not being around the Powder
Keg
um but it didn't happen and I was able
to catch my breath and then look back
and help
um you know fix my part of the
relationship or at least make steps
towards fixing it great and is he
becoming a safer place for your daughter
to be around
um did you just refer to it as a powder
keg if I'm a 17 year old girl I'm out I
can't I can't it's too disregulated I
can't be around that it he um he is much
better but they
um neither one of the two
um acknowledge any growth and because
they still have a lot of
um trauma from the childhood and it the
problem was I worked second shift so
they were home
um with him and I wasn't there to
mediate like apparently that's the thing
I do all my life so yeah you got to stop
that if you have an abusive husband
he's got to be away from the kids
or here's what they're gonna do they're
going to turn to adults who never talk
to you all again
yeah and if he's not safe good for them
for getting out because you should have
got him out a long time ago and you know
that
and you're free to work through it great
wonderful it sounds like your daughter
is in a
hyper chaotic environment relationally
physiologically psychologically it feels
chaotic
and my guess is they also do what go
ahead there's there's also there's also
the weed factor in there where they both
think that that will help with their
anxiety and depression and so hold on
hold on hold on
whenever a kid who's 18 comes to me and
says I have to do this
my response is not man you gotta quit
you gotta quit drinking right help like
you got to quit smoking weed
my first question is good Lord what has
happened in your home that is so chaotic
that this is the only way you can
navigate through it
and they're probably smoking weed right
now in because it works
it's a terrible long-term strategy but
it's better than the alternative
which is it's sitting inside of a of a
ping ball
like a
sitting inside of a
I don't know uh what do you call it a
bingo ball Turner right that's the world
they live in inside of a blender
all right is that fair
um yeah just some some degree it's
because there has been change with him
they just won't interact with him if he
walks in the room you know my daughter
jumps back like he's on fire
um and they won't
um or they haven't been able to
um he's offered to sit with them in
therapy to go to a counselor he's going
to counseling but
um
I've had her in and out of counseling
but for whatever reason she'll bail on
the people or we've had struggles trying
to connect with providers because of
schedule Insurance all that and I said
I'll pay out of pocket and they go I
can't
um and okay well and we'll schedule you
in six months and she's saying somebody
at school now but it's um
I can't even I don't even know what to
do with all the even the radioactivity
from her
um
outside of him yes it's it's it's a part
of her now
you can't expect there to be a a great
summer
after she attempts suicide or is
suicidal ideation
a great summer that 18 years of
collective chaos suddenly dissipates
this is Years Years okay so you're gonna
have to be patient with your with your
child and I know they have an adult age
18.
um but there's a little girl in there
that's still protecting herself from her
dad because nobody else would or nobody
else did
and I don't know what Dad did I don't
know if he was yelled and screamed and
scared the little girls or if he was
abusive I don't know
but their bodies it was just
soak up and their bodies are telling
them not now and so I would honor that
I would say you have to be respectful
in this house
but you don't have to hug him
if you don't want to sit down and have a
one-on-one conversation you don't have
to do that right now
he's working on it
and he has to be a grown man and know
that he sowed seeds for 18 years and
this is the fruit
and you can't sow seeds of chaos and
rage and anger and screaming at your
little kids
and they get mad when they grow up and
have to have alternative ways to try to
self-regulate because they didn't learn
that at home
and I got no skills
and the two people they were supposed to
be anchored in the most
were I mean we're Jello right there was
nowhere to Anchor into and they felt
like they were untethered like it's just
part of it you got to be respectful and
you can't you can't make up lies about
me you can't throw grenades at me I
won't be here punching back
and
I have to understand the chickens come
home to rest
so they're here and now we have to ask
ourselves what do we want this to look
like in 10 years
let's begin healing that way your kids
can or your husband can talk the talk
and talk the talk and I'm going to
counseling
those girls will
feel safe when their bodies tell them
we're safe
which means he's going to have to act
differently for a long period of time
he's gonna have to act different he's
gonna have to provide a safe environment
he's gonna have to write those girls a
letter and say I'm sorry
I wasn't who I should have been
and I'm trying to be different now
and my hope is over time
you'll come to love the new me because
I'm working really hard at it
but I'm not fighting with my kid over an
Amazon account I'm just gonna tell him
no
I'm not fighting with my kid over the
definitions of gasoline you're a
narcissist you're a guestler those are
the two most overused internet social
media nonsense descriptors
that are actual Diagnostics right it's
just throwing her I'm not I'm not gonna
do that you can have your story and I
could be sad that you have bad memories
of Dad I can be heartbroken and grieving
and then I'm going to be on about being
the adult and about trying to grow
adults and I'm going to change my
relationships moving forward because
that's all I can do
your daughters deserve that in and you
do too